comic-book universes are often cited as
mythologies of the modern era Superman
spider-man Wonder Woman the Hulk these
are the new gods the sidon apollo zeus
of our debt but the strongest
similarities between greek myth and
american comics have less to do with the
characters or their supernatural powers
than with an ever growing interweaving
tapestry of story there would be very
little force for example in Aeschylus is
Oresteia the story of arrestees revenge
on his mother Clytemnestra murder of her
husband Agamemnon arrestees father if
the story of Agamemnon have not already
been told in Homer's Iliad the dark
family history of Agamemnon is assumed
in Aeschylus tragedy all its symbolisms
of rape murder and incest augment the
rsd a--'s expansion of it that same idea
goes for Frank Miller's The Dark Knight
Returns the nuage tale of a geriatric
Batman coming out of retirement
Miller drew on what was then 48 years of
Batman stories from Bob Kane to Dennis
O'Neil from 60s camp to 70s brooding all
of it informs The Dark Knight Returns
introspective depiction of a beast at
war with the man who embodies it both
stories draw depth from the narrative
universes
to which they belong more depth than
either could achieve alone and the
stories that came after use these in the
same way this is a unique feature of
mythology every story lends special
weight to every other shared characters
develop a life's worth of pain triumph
anxiety affection and as the tapestry
grows larger and tighter individual
threads become more sensitive to effects
on others and the whole it's why we keep
returning to Greek myth it's why we love
comic books when it comes to film Marvel
Comics understands with Iron Man The
Incredible Hulk Captain America the
First Avenger and Thor Marvel rolled out
an incredible and incredibly successful
campaign to entwine
its heroes world the first phase as they
called it featured origin stories a
necessary hurdle average film goers
weren't familiar with Thor or I
then with the groundwork laid in a
number of hints that something bigger
was on the way Marvel Studios delivered
the Avengers the first shared universe
comic film it's hard to overstate the
impact of this under the guidance of
Joss Whedon the Avengers came off
beautifully but the real payoff was next
with Iron Man 3 Marvel released a film
in which the facts of a shared universe
fed back and added special way to Tony
Stark's new life and story it's
something more than a sequel it's
something that's never been done before
and film
compared to this DC Comics heroes are
hopelessly alone they exist awkwardly on
separate film island Superman doesn't
know Batman Green Lantern doesn't know
Wonder Woman or Martian Manhunter or
Aquaman nobody knows the flash
Christopher Nolan did a superb job with
Batman Begins in The Dark Knight but his
Gotham City has no sister in Metropolis
every hero is the first of its kind
hopefully the upcoming Superman vs
Batman movie is a sign that DC's
starting to get its act together of
course they've cast it Ben Affleck but
that's another story there are even
rumors that a Justice League movie the
superior analog of the Avengers in my
opinion is in the cars for 2017 fingers
and toes crossed who knows what phase
Marvel will be in by then the stories
can only get deeper and more complex
it's a big production to full directors
and actors and writers into a shared
universe but it's worth all that trouble
if the product is a whole new class of
cinema hey everybody thanks for watching
I'm a huge comic book fan and comic book
movie fan you might know that from some
previous videos I'm a DC person I've
always read DC Comics Superman has been
my favorite superhero forever so it's so
painful to watch what DC is doing in
their film universe especially giving
Zack Snyder the reins to Superman and
Batman and it just it pains me a lot if
you have an idea for a topic you'd like
me to cover write it in the comments and
also I love your comments keep
commenting I'm going to try to respond
to as many as I can
hopefully I
all of them thanks for watching and I'll
see you next time